I'd written into the script this comic
book guru
I guess it's kind of like in their world
it'd be like a Stan Lee he's like wow
just write it for Stan Lee and I was
like I don't know Stan Lee and he goes I
do and I was like Hollywood is good
hey man I'm Kevin Smith G's EMU and we
play Jay and Silent Bob you remembered
[Music]
yeah I met Jason 32 years ago at this
point we both grew up in the town of
Highlands in New Jersey and Jason was
the figure of suburban legend so people
be like there's that Jay Mewes he broke
the window at Cumberland Farms where
there's that kid Jay Mewes I hear he
[ __ ] a dog once which he didn't right
no no but everyone would say stuff
boundaries figure of mystery people knew
him and stuff so one day he came to my
house and my mom was like that dirty boy
from town it is here and I was like whoo
and I looked out it was Jason and I was
like Jason Mewes is here why no went out
to answer the door I was like what are
you doing here and he goes what are we
doing today
and so I kind of adopted him I was drawn
to him they would talk about comics and
movies and they use big words which is
funny now but they did they use I mean
my friends we went outside but these
guys they sat inside and talked about
comic books big words with the internet
before I was appealing those appealing
to me as a 13 year old said like what is
what are they saying they're saying
things like ostentatious what does that
mean that is magical and they would talk
about girls like I 14 I had never even
kissed a girl and they actually had a
couple girlfriends a couple but Neng at
that age they they knew stuff so I
wanted to hang out him as much as
possible plus he had a lot of cool like
he had a lot he had a room full of comic
books and he had tons of VHS tapes and
movies and stuff so I don't know I just
that that's what I remember about him
plus I had seen him sounds like I'm a
pedo it's like he had comics and movies
that the circuit even UPenn I was out in
the woods with my friends and he said
come hang out with us we got big words
for you so horrible so we open this room
up and there's a game room and like
candy and sobs and plus he had a car and
he drove us so he would drive us to the
comic book store hard stuff but he had a
white panel van we know
knows he called it the fun buggy I don't
remember it being fun but somehow were
friends there's a lot I blacked out I
guess there's a bed in the back I just
remember that I think it as a
thirteen-year-old that's what I
remembered like it was super appealing
all these things were appealing to me
because again I could go out and have
fun
my friends but I'd like oh I wonder what
Kevin's doing I want to go hang out with
him cuz he's gonna show me Full Metal
Jacket in these movies he says so much
to me he had like knowledge of all
movies and and directors and they would
talk about writers and my friends would
just play cages Sydney Van Damme movie
and like which was again great but like
he would be like did you see the Van
Damme movie who was written by Joe Bob
Billy Bob and directed by you know
Scorsese which never what you're hearing
here is that I knew the credits of the
movies because of that I was smarter
than most of the people he knew it yes
we became really good friends and I
think he's the most like original human
being I've ever met like hands down an
American original through most of our
lives before I made the movie I would
always be like man you're funny but I
wonder if anyone would find you funny
outside of like New Jersey somebody
should put you in a movie one day and
find out like you're funny to people
like in Chicago or something like that
and then years later when I was like
whoo I want to make a movie one of the
first things I thought is like I'm
putting Jason Mewes in the movie because
he's like the funniest person I know the
most original person I want to see if
anyone else thinks that snoogantay kim
outside the convenience store like as
one of the dealers I worked at quick
stop and you always had teenage weed
dealers hanging outside the building and
stuff and never one of them there's
always like a group or at least two one
guy deal and one guys is muscle and
stuff and then I didn't want to give him
somebody to talk to because I wanted to
showcase all the stuff he says I'm like
he's way more interesting when you just
let him go so I was like imma stick
somebody next to him a character who's
his muscle but don't say anything like
there's a character in this movie I
loved called my favorite ear herb one of
the writers never spoke throughout the
whole movie and he'd always kind of
whisper to one of the other
and like in the midst of the chaos of
the third act you know one point they
cut two herb and he goes my god this
makes me happy and everyone stops and
looks at him cuz he hasn't said anything
little movie and then the movie just
goes back on it's tough so I like that
knows I carry man I could stick somebody
next to Jay doesn't say anything and Jay
is just talking to him all the time and
and I went with the name Silent Bob
because I was big fan of Twin Peaks and
Bob was one of the characters there was
a Mike and Bob that lived above the
grocery store of bub to the convenience
store so I went with Bob it just sounded
kind of normal also Bob the goon like
from Batman Tim Burton 99 Batman he
didn't really speak throughout the movie
and stuff so I had to pick a name and I
went with Bob I couldn't name his
character anything but Jay like he never
occurred to me to give him a fictional
name like Dirty Harry or whatever it's
just like he was Jay and Jay was Jay so
it became Jay and Silent Bob
smoochie booty knew jeez honestly my ID
it started off as Ned Ned just started
off as meaning just kidding because I at
13 14 I was told always kidding with my
friends and or people and and I wanted
to make sure they knew I was joking
around
so he didn't get hit it began as net and
it was almost like this weird nervous
tic the kid was always going Nick yeah
yeah and then it grew he started
finessing it so he'd be like no H and
then like nooch and the same thing I
slept with your mom nooch you know he
got through a dutch on it and then it
would grow where he'd be like I slept
with your mom last nice Nucci big cheese
you know and stuff like that and I it
was amazing I watched language grow they
got a douche stuff for almost for my own
entertainment like is almost like a
nervous tic like you said like I
wouldn't I would do things but I would
say it to entertain myself his good
explanation is the story in the library
when I busted in the library would
kicked in the door and I didn't look at
you guys and I was doing stuff so now
you got to finish the story man so he
tells a good story about he members and
I remember sort of this he was in a poor
me and wall or at the Rec and we were
bagging and board in our comic books and
all the sudden is quiet no kids were
there for the kids came from at 3
o'clock all sudden the door boom gets
kicked open and Jason Mewes marches in
and proceeds to fellate anything
somewhat phallic in the room so he grabs
a pool stick and he's sucking it off he
grabs the phone and he's second up the
flagpole sucking the Eagle off and me
and Walter watched him go from item to
item and he never looked at us it was
never like look at this right it was as
almost as if like he was walking around
town gone oh it's 2 o'clock I better go
to the record suck everything off and so
we sat there and watched him and then he
reached the asteroids machine and
asteroid the kiosk for those that don't
remember has no joystick there was
nothing phallic for him to work and we
were like what's gonna happen here is he
stood there frozen and then he shrugged
him I thought about of that on the
roller ball set on the buttons so I was
like man I I want to hang out with his
kid he's a genius and he's very orally
fixated so that's kind of guy for me
that's when I knew like you know this is
somebody should see this besides us he
would work for an audience of two or
none and like it was like throwing away
gold where I'm like this is legit funny
so years later after like hanging out of
a couple years when I was like I'm gonna
be a filmmaker
I just remembered all the hits you know
the greatest hits and I was like I'm
gonna have him do this I'm gonna have
him do this and just to have him be an
energy and as a player in the movie was
something that felt like it might it
might work I just want to see if anyone
finds it funny and when it came out and
nobody talked about us nobody was ever
like Jay and Silent Bob there's one
review that mentioned Jay specifically
they'd mentioned me a LOX though like in
parentheses and the director also plays
a character named Silent Bob but they
never talked about Jay and Silent Bob
and then there was a review but I think
it was Lea Rosen in People magazine and
she said Jason Mewes you want to find
the rock he crawled out from under and
make sure there's nothing else like it
under that rock and he showed me that
review he's like this good I was like
that's a rave man so we had no idea that
there was any sort of awareness for the
characters until Mallrats
like the first time we did a screen
Mallrats at the san diego comic-con 1995
Horton Plaza like that was a screening
about 200 people and clerks had gotten a
home video but we hadn't thought about
that
so all of a sudden Jay and Silent Bob
come up on the screen and the audience
erupted with recognition and that blew
me away where I'm like what how and then
I realized oh they because people have
seen clerks down home video and stuff so
suddenly we knew that like oh people
liked him what is this [ __ ] everyone's
looking for us today we're dunking
Trisha because she wants to talk that'll
be one here about her video setup so I
so I had her audition
for Jay and Mallrats and and it was
because the the studio was like hey
we're giving you this much money and
again I'm he probably could tell it
better because he was dealing with the
producers and the casting and all that
Jay had to play Jay but the studio was
like he's your friend like this is a
funny role that could go to a real actor
yeah and so they made us audition a
bunch of people and I've still felt like
he's the guy like even in the Adam
audition against other Jays Seth Seth
Green was one of our Paul Gosselaar he
was like you know I know everybody sees
me as Zach but what about Jay and we
were like huh but Seth Green in the
studio liked and Rec admire hmm so and
Brecon went on to be in clueless and
stuff so there were two guys that there
were like these are the dudes that we
want to play Jay and then you know when
I was we did a pizza playoff like we had
pizza and all the cast was there the
studio got to see all the different Jays
the different Brody's so forth and so on
at the end of the day like he shined it
was clear that he was the guy but at the
same time the studio was like I don't
know if it's you know we're here we'll
do this for you you could bring him out
to Minnesota that's where we shot the
food we're not gonna fly him out I'm
gonna put him up for your month of
rehearsal so if you want him there you
fly him out you put him up and when we
see his first day of dailies if we don't
like him he's gone and we're bringing in
Seth Green so I said okay and so you
know we had a month rehearse and stuff
and he got familiar and comfy with
everybody
and the big thing was like you have to
be able to act in front of people he
couldn't do it on clerks like on clerks
it's the dance scene out in front of the
store like he was like I was like I man
this is the scene all we do is dance
he's no dialogue we just dance like you
always do
he's like I can't dance it for all these
people and it was literally just the DP
Dave Klein and Scott Mosier the producer
so those dudes had to like go into rst
video and hide beyond the door and the
camera had it was taped down so it would
just run on and recorders and stuff and
so I'm Mallrats it was more about learn
how to work in front of other so that
you not you don't clam up and stuff like
that and the first day he was great like
I thought he was great but we sent the
dailies into the studio and we were
fingers crossed waiting to hear back
from him they said all right he could
stay and then they started paying him
from that day yeah oh my god
holy [ __ ] aren't you
Oh Stanley I I don't know everyone calls
a cameo but to me I'm like he was
actually one of the supporting
characters like he's in the movie quite
a bit and he was in there because like
we loved him I'd written into the script
this comic book guru and Jim Jack's the
producer was like hey man who is this
supposed to be and I said well I guess
it's kind of like in their world it'd be
like a Stan Lee and he's like wow geez
write it for Stan Lee and I was like I
don't know Stan Lee and he goes I do and
I was like Hollywood is good so Jim
Jack's asked Stan if you wanted to be in
it and Stan said yeah and we got to meet
him in Minnesota for the first time and
like me Jason and Walter was there with
us we were beside ourselves because this
was Stan Lee and you know at the time
comic book people knew who he was but
like outside accountable people he
wasn't insanely well-known 10 years
changed later he would become the guy
that's in the Where's Waldo of the mall
from Marvel movies and everybody would
know him the world over your mom your
grandma would know who Stan Lee was and
stuff so in mall rats we were able to be
like for a new generation that maybe
wasn't familiar with like comics or who
created the co-created some of these
great characters we were able to
introduce be like hey here's
spider-man's baby
and years later when they made the
Captain Marvel movie stands on the train
and he's reading the script for Mallrats
it says Mallrats by kevin smith and in
that way he kind of introduced me
returned the favor like years later he
introduced me to a bunch of kids don't
know who the hell I am by way of that
little like script cameo instead so he
was he was a friend man he loved Jason
he did his last cameo was in Jason's
movie very last last thing ever done and
Jason when Jason shot with him that day
you could tell him that I cried yeah
yeah so Stan was awesome Stan came down
I shot a directing my first feature girl
called madness in the method I'm
actually excited it's playing in Russia
like in the next couple days you're
colluding yeah Stan always jokes me
Kevin because Kevin's put him in more
outs and Kevin's a director writer and
he's always it when you put me in your
next movie so I'm like well he always
tells Kevin he wants so maybe he'll go
in my movies so I was like do you think
he would be in a movie that I'm
directing and I were and I'm gonna be
part of and he's like his guy was like
yeah he'll come down for like two hours
you can have him but he has to be home
by 6:00 cos he'll will not miss dinner
with his wife and I thought that was so
sweet but he came down and and he was
super awesome and we finally got him the
camera ready and we started shooting and
and we did like three takes of the one
thing and we did a couple more after but
the first one I said oh can you do it
again can you do this and say something
different than like I walked away am i
you know I got a little teary eyed so
meaning Stan was awesome first and then
seeing him every time on him saying
hello to me was great and then for him
to be in my movie so you know I had a
moment and I stepped away I was like
yeah yeah the reboot we dedicated to
Stan he was meant to be in it he was
supposed to be the guy in the third eye
he was the entire third act he was the
dude that's meant to be on stage that
our villains are after and of course
unfortunately we lost him so we had this
little piece that we had shot on the
Daboo IMD boat during San Diego
comic-con a couple years ago with Stan
where I was like hey man let's do some
dialogue from the movie like a little
kind of audition thing and he was so
like wonderful in the clip like he just
he's not even putting on the Stan Lee
character he just starts cracking up and
just being himself and I love the clip
so much so I was like let's head in the
movie with it you might watch that too
yeah yeah that's pretty great stuff like
he you know he's right like hearing his
voice it's like a time machine and it
just took you to better times in your
life or at a moment's you know the
formative moments with your friends and
stuff I remember after Dogma like you
know we had a lot of photography when
Dogma a lot of big actors and stuff and
unlike clerks like all the reviews
talked about Jay and Silent Bob and I'll
never forget like Matt Damon at the we
did you know our New York Film Festival
premiere of Dogma we're on the stage at
Alice Tully and during the Q&A like Matt
Damon was just like look nobody's sang
it but I'll say it he's going Jason
Mewes stole the movie out from under
everybody on this stage and like the
whole crowd went nuts and applauded and
stuff like that so we went through a lot
of Hell like pun intended on Dogma with
some religious cult cats and there were
death threats so after that I was like
well the next movie I'm gonna make
something that's just fun and like
hopefully we don't get death threats
like something that nobody could be
offended by and since they played so
well in Dogma and also I should give a
little bit of shout-out to West Craven
as well after Dogma we did this tiny
piece and scream 3 because that's where
I'm at West where Jay and Silent Bob
popped up in scream 3 and and we did the
Connie Chung bit and so because it was
it the same lot we'd eventually shoot
strike backers CBS Radford yeah and we
were there for a day and I remember
being on the lot and being like this
would be fun and like to be on an actual
movie studio a lot and shoot a movie and
stuff and Jane saw Bob and Hollywood
that's kind of funny so it all kind of
coalesced and came together and I
said you know what let's do a movie
that's like you and me like you know
we'll be the leaves this time around a
Jay and Silent Bob adventure and he you
know he was all for it by that point he
wasn't against it at all but there were
drugs back then as well yeah that was
the difficulty man like getting him
clean used to be a problem because he
fell into heroin and oxycontin and stuff
like that and so like Dogma was like
getting ready for Dogma was a Herculean
effort and then getting ready for Jay
and Silent Bob strike back was like the
same thing it was about like keeping him
away from drugs rehabbing him at the
house and stuff like that and you know
Jay and Silent Bob might be the reason
he's still above ground because it was
always this kind of you know well you
got to get clean man or else we don't do
this so it would be something you could
use to keep him on the straight and
narrow but like then the movie would end
and you couldn't stop him Jay and Silent
Bob strike back he was clean throughout
no drugs but he drank yes he's got like
some kind of James blows in his face in
the movie like I remember one point the
guy who in charge of dimension called up
he said saw the dailies and said hey man
should we get Jay a trainer and I was
like why he's gone there's a shot where
we know you guys are hanging over the
camera in the huddle he's going he's got
bigger turkey neck than you and I was
like don't he's trying to be off drugs
don't tell him he's got to lose weight
as well so he on strike back the moment
we stop shooting in Jersey the moment we
rapped like boom II fell back down into
the drug hole again so that was always
kind of difficult and probably one of
the main reasons why like we didn't do
more Jay and Silent Bob stuff you know
it's hard for me to watch my performance
in any of the movies drugs are not drugs
honestly because I always feel like I
watched myself and I'm like I could have
been funnier here or I shoulda gave this
look I should have done that so and with
or without drugs so I don't really feel
but again him of course I know like
there was like oh wow that day I was
like you know in the bathroom every five
minutes and I kept saying like all my
stomach hurts you know saw I remember
like these bad moments but it was always
tough I don't know why for towards the
end I'd always like it almost like it's
almost over and I cannot celebrate now
by ziran addicts oh yeah just like I
just gotta get through this and I can
get back to doing what I really want to
do J racers you're about to I think I'm
gonna need to see a blood test it's
almost 10 years now you've been clean
yeah and the big difference maker at
first it was the podcast we did saw Bob
util but then he had a kid and he had
Logan and that that was everything
suddenly like all his priorities snapped
into place and you know this would be
the dude you joke about he wouldn't give
him up he wouldn't be in charge of a
dozen eggs let alone another human being
let alone a small human being but he
turned out to be like super-dead
hands-down the best dad I've ever seen
in my life and I include myself as a dad
in that equation and even my father like
because you know I don't know if it's
because of ease because he's got like a
million-dollar heart probably but
something to do with his upbringing and
made him super dad because he didn't
know his dad or whatever
he's not even overcompensating he's just
doing it the way it's supposed to be
done like I'm almost I almost wish he
had had a kid long before it makes that
would've been like oh that's how you do
it and that's kind of where reboot came
from you know he'd been we've been
talking about on tour like he's always
like when are we gonna make another Jay
and Bob movie I'm like never like we did
it once and that was it but then I would
use it to I was like stay sober maybe we
will make another Jay and Silent Bob
movie and then one day it came to it and
then the story kind of wrote itself
because he was a dad in real life and it
was so amusing to see him be this
incredible dad like he relates to the
kid like I've never seen an adult relate
to their own child and like it might be
because even though he's 45 and she's
four they're emotionally on the same way
or whatever but like it's a really warm
wonderful relationship and I was like
I'm gonna do that for the movie and so I
stole his real life and put in the flick
what I loved him is that I over the
years he's like sort of adapted our
characters based on where him and I are
like clerks to is like I just got out of
rehab and the Holy Bible son and all
that stuff and it's because I had
literally had just gotten out of six
months rehab and I had like some time
clean and you know clerks I was super
obnoxious
and you could see it like I'm yelling
like oh if anything that moves in all
this stuff and then Mallrats them a
little bit goofy or snooty boo cheese
and and so just as I think it's always
sort of grown a little bit with that and
so I mean again it's perfect I think
it's I think this movie honestly it is
super clever and I'm just saying this
because he's here but I think he's super
clever and how he's ties in all the
other movies how he's brought it to
where I'm because I'm a dad in real life
and I've been so well and I'm married
for a while and like James Jay and Bob
are grown-up but it's my two dads and
it's I don't know and then his daughters
in the film it's my two does we
literally stole this baby my two that
[Music]
you ever [ __ ] licked by a fat man in
an overcoat the entire series that's my
life it's one of them yeah I mean it's
on the screen but meeting Stan if we're
going back like that is about of my
favorite mall rats you know but that's
one of your character never misses no I
know that's why I'm saying my character
this is my favorite moment still love
those movies it comes down to this
I would irritate me when when people
would talk about clerks like all my
favorite part is when you guys dance in
the dark and I'm like nobody says
anything like that movies all about
dialogue it was always like well weird
backhanded compliment my favorite moment
in any of the movies hands down belongs
to him and Harley they have this kind of
quasi breakup moment in the movie where
they have to kind of go their separate
ways and the two of them were absolutely
dazzling I I cry every time I watch it
and I honestly believe for those few
seconds that they're not the two people
I know like they transcend with their
performance and I forget she's my kid
and I forget he's him and I go like
these poor people like if they could
just get their [ __ ] to
like she's she needs a dad he needs to
do it Oh makes me upset
even though not upset but like happy
truth and it was him and her they blew
the doors off that moment of everything
I've ever done that stands out
[Music]